Llegado el fin de año,
Feijóo y compañía se merecen 1 resumen de susitos
2023/1. Insultos a Sánchez
es 1 caricatura de Presidente de gobierno
como la 5ª planta del Corte Inglés.
Imagen y sonido,
Sánchez no le llega la camisa al cuello.
La decadencia del poder
en el otoño del patriarca.
Segundo, mentiras, teníamos 1 pacto de estado,
lo habíamos firmado todos, todos, salvo podemos.
Nuestro partido nunca dejó de revalorizar las pensiones
conforme al IPC.
No es correcto, señor fijo,
es que es absolutamente correcto.
No lo hicieron ni en 2 012 ni en 2 013,
ni en el año 2 000.
Yo no sé de dónde saca usted eso.
Compromiso que tenemos como partido es
revalorizar las pensiones de acuerdo con el IPC.
Recuerde que votamos así. Abordado en contra,
ha sido el Presidente de 1 comunidad autónoma
que menos ha incrementado la deuda pública de España.
Tercero, más insultos
es cuando entra en acción Pedro Sánchez,
ese político trilero
que cambia las reglas del juego
para ver si no nos damos cuenta.
4º más mentiras. Yo no vengo a insultar a Pedro Sánchez,
vengo a ganar a Pedro Sánchez.
5º perder la selección.
Yo no soy Presidente porque no me vendo
ni vendo a los españoles.
Nace la original teoría
de, no soy Presidente porque no quiero